un écran qui se plie en 3 c'est le
Samsung Flex s alors c'est pas le tout
une technologie qui va arriver tout de
suite on se parle bien ici de
technologie que Samsung commence à
montrer mais les usages sont
intéressants pourquoi parce que ce qui
nous intéresse c'est la modularité c'est
d'abord des smartphones qui rétrécit
sans tailles comme le Samsung Galaxy Z
flip c'est des smartphones qui vont
agrandir de taille qui vont grandir dire
de plus en plus grand comme le Galaxy Z3
Et pourquoi pas venir avoir une énorme
tablette qu'après on repli un peu comme
un accordéon c'est toute la promesse qui
est faite ici par Samsung sur le stand
de Samsung display parce que Samsung
display est une entité du groupe Samsung
dont Samsung électronique ce qui vous
vend des appareils fait partie on monte
cette techno ici sur un salon je trouve
ça juste extraordinaire pour essayer de
te projeter un peu dans le futur et voir
ce qui va arriver ça s'appelle le flex S
c'est Samsung qui monte ça arrivera
peut-être plus tard d'ailleurs est-ce
que ce type d'écran pliable pourrait
vous botter en trois parties dites-moi
ce que vous en pensez bien évidemment
dans les commentaires